okay everybody so this is my review of
nine perfect strangers episode seven
wheels on the bus this is the pen
ultimate episode of the season
we did not get screeners for this
episode so i am going to redo this
review off the cuff i am recording this
review as the episode has dropped on
hulu uh so what i really noticed too
about this show is that what really
hurts it is that because it's on hulu
the problem with hulu is that hulu has a
subscription that allows commercials so
they cut these shows
on these weird cuts
to put commercials in so it feels like
almost you're watching an edit that
would be on a network show really
frustrating that's the advantage when
shows are in hbo or on netflix they
don't get interrupted they're not cut
that way so
again this is a show that would really
have benefited if they had just left the
edit for non-commercials but because of
business they have to have this version
so they can get those commercials in for
those people who subscribe with the
commercials in it
now that's just the frustration i have
again because with a show like this it
just really sucks it sucks that that
happens and because it sucks if you feel
it even in an episode that's supposed to
have all this momentum there's just
these odd moments it stops and then
comes back
you never really get in the flow and
that's been a problem the whole season
so
with this episode
you know i it's like this is the best
you're gonna get now with twists right
like if you're waiting for a show like
this sitting through a lot of the
slowness of it you want a big choice in
pen ultimate episode is it that carmel
being
the person who shot masha is that a
great twist i don't really know i think
it's a little predictable
uh it's not the most like jaw-dropping
thing it came off a little cheesy once
you put the contact in too
uh but you know what i'm gonna take away
from this episode from this season just
as a whole is that regina hall is
killing it as carmel and regina hall has
just blown me away because i only knew
her from scary movie movies and her
comedy acting i didn't know she had this
in her to do this dramatic acting i mean
if i was like this big casting director
a hollywood agent like i would be
calling the phone of her
her representation like now like get her
in everything she is so good i mean i
have not seen a performance this good in
so long it's just because she just seems
so
in the role like it's not regina hall
it's crazy and the range she's doing
here is just spectacular so i mean she
rightfully so she'll start blowing up
now as a dramatic actress and definitely
has to be a frontrunner for an emmy for
this performance it's so deserved
so
you know this episode
it's interesting it it still again feels
like a show where like not a lot's
happening but it looks like a lot's
happening but really not that much and
there's inconsistencies in this episode
that frustrate me where
we're used to the group to this point
kind of being on the same dosage of
drugs and them kind of making clear each
episode who's on what and how much
but they kind of skimped on that
with
having melissa mccarthy's character of
francis still being you know tripping
out here but a character like lars seems
like super sober super sharp in the
brain at the moment so you're kind of
like did he skip dosage like what's
going on it feels confusing i wish they
clarified
what was the decision that morning with
certain characters and how much they
were taking it was kind of all over the
place and inconsistent so it felt kind
of odd that i knew lars being in that
pool scene last episode tripping with
everybody and now he seems like he's
clearly not taking any drugs but i want
to see that i want to be that confirmed
like that's a big decision also the
character of yao at this point just
seems like he's just hesitant with
everything and he's just kind of there
uh his behavior was weird this episode
that
you know
i wish we had some meat to his character
when delilah was making this big
decision to leave and possibly go to the
police he was kind of just like ugh like
he's always just like uh you know arm
shrug emoji for yeah this whole show but
give us a response to that maybe we can
learn more about him and why he's doing
what he's doing and letting delilah
leave because that's such a significant
thing for her to go to the police so
that was odd there's moments i really
like though i really like actually the
scene of francis and masha on the cliff
here and they're talking about
you know both having lost their parents
at a young age or fathers in particular
matcha opens up about her daughter again
the problem with the show is they give
the audience information before it's
revealed to the characters so when it's
revealed we don't feel that impact that
maybe francis was feeling hearing about
masha's daughter dying we learned this
last episode so
why not save that for that moment again
i think they just take away from a
moment supposed to be big by revealing
them you know prior to that big line so
a very strange decision uh what i do
enjoy about this show and it continues
this episode is the camera work the
cinematography and the way jonathan
levine
you know edits and decides to cut
certain shots that make you feel like
you are tripping out particularly i
really like what they were doing with
francis and masha's conversation the
kitchen you didn't really know what was
really being said and what was being you
know hallucinated and that same thing
goes with her talking to tony um i feel
like they've totally flubbed the
storyline with jessica and ben again
there's so many mouths to feed so you're
expecting someone's story line to start
faltering especially because it's a
limited series and there's only so many
episodes but jessica and ben you're
really feeling that i mean the whole
point it felt like of
you know jessica's character was to say
the wheels on the bus line the title of
the episode and keep saying it and
reaffirming it you know it just felt
kind of like yeah i wish we got more
meat to them so they've kind of fizzled
out in this show
uh you know it really centered on the
marconis now which is still interesting
stuff and i like finally that mash is
deciding to take these drugs with them
we want to see what happens with masha
here because we now know she wants to
get back also to who she lost her
daughter so she's using the marconis for
that that's been made more clear uh it
does set up a really exciting finale i
mean how can it not now that you have
carmel here
and she's revealed herself to masha
while mosh is under the influence as is
the marconi so
i keep saying that shit's gonna hit the
fan but it really still kind of hasn't
it's just like tiptoes so
i don't know i think it was okay but at
the end of the day how far we've come
with seven episodes of eight this
episode just made me feel you know a
little let down i was expecting
something more unique and exciting to
happen here with all the characters
and uh it was just kind of a twist the
big twist of the show that carmel is the
one who shot masha it's just like okay
cool you know it's it's not that
shocking it's not that game changing
really it isn't because we already knew
that she already kind of had a gripe
with masha because we got the bigger
twist that you know masha was sleeping
with her ex-husband so
yeah it kind of felt flat to me and i
think this whole show we can kind of
look at now is it's a little
disappointing with such a good cast you
know
it's just not that great it's not bad
but it's not great you know it's gonna
be forgettable i don't think this is the
show
after it airs that it will live on and
people talk about it and suggest to
their friends i think it's kind of just
there you know so
this was the episode to kind of maybe
take it to the next level and it did not
to me the show did not hit its ceiling
uh so it's decent but it's hard to rate
this episode because on its own it's not
bad but what you're expecting now at
this point being the second last episode
you want more
so
you know i'm gonna give this one
an a 7.9 i think that's fair because it
had some good moments it was more
entertaining than many episodes but
still at slow moments and again this
jolted editing feels weird with the cuts
for commercials
um and you know i think what i'm just
enjoying the most at this point is
watching for regina hall's performance
it's spectacular and every scene she's
in has been really interesting because
of her performance and how good she's
bringing 150 so it's fun to watch
but
i'm really not even that interested in
this show anymore but i will be watching
the finale i'll be reviewing it
unfortunately we're not getting
screeners for that either so i'm gonna
have to off the cuff it next wednesday
so please join me in that um
and yeah i mean please share this video
if you can like comment i'd love to hear
your thoughts i read every comment try
to respond as many as i can
if you really like what i do here i can
really appreciate the support if you
sign up to be a member get exclusive
perks and it will help me do this
full-time and do more reviews for you
guys i love the support so i can do all
the shows like succession dexter wheel
of time all of it i wanna i wanna cover
as much as i can but i'm still working a
full-time job and it's hard to do
when you have so many things you're
juggling
and doing interviews as well so it's a
lot but i'm doing my best and any
support i can
you know get really would help i'm
ranting here but follow me at steve are
the show on twitter instagram and tick
tock as well for more of me that helps
me so much as well you have no idea pick
a pick an app follow me reach out to me
i'm here i'm a friend i'm here for you
let's watch some tv and enjoy
uh yeah and i'll see you guys
next week